Malgré l'énorme influence de la religion dans le monde d'aujourd'hui,
nous ne sommes pas aussi vigilants et ne les tenons pas autant responsables
que n'importe quel autre secteur de notre société.
Par exemple, s'ils étaient une organisation internationale,
un gouvernement ou une entreprise
qui dirait qu'aucune femme ne peut être dirigeante,
qu'aucune femme ne peut avoir de pouvoir de décision,
qu'aucune femme ne peut gérer des questions financières,
nous serions outragés.
Il y aurait des sanctions.
Pourtant, cela est une pratique courante dans presque toutes les religions.
Nous acceptons des choses dans notre vie religieuse
que nous n'acceptons pas dans notre vie séculière.
Et je le sais car je le fais depuis des dizaines d'années.
Grandissant, j'étais le genre de fille qui combattait toute discrimination sexuelle.
Je jouais au basketball avec les garçons.
Je disais que j'allais être la première femme présidente des États-Unis.
Je me suis battue pour l'Equal Right Amendment,
qui était mort depuis 40 ans.
Je suis la première femme de toute ma famille
à avoir travaillé en dehors de la maison et à avoir suivi des études supérieures.
Je n'ai jamais accepté d'être exclue parce que je suis une femme,
sauf dans ma religion.
Pendant tout ce temps,
j'étais membre d'une religion mormone orthodoxe très patriarche.
J'ai grandi dans une famille très traditionnelle.
J'ai huit frères et sœurs, une mère au foyer.
Mon père est un dirigeant religieux dans la communauté.
J'ai grandi dans un monde qui croit que ma valeur et mon prestige
demeuraient dans la préservation de ces règles que j'ai toujours connues.
Vous vous mariez vierge, ne buvez jamais d'alcool,
ne fumez pas, priez toujours,
vous êtes un bon gamin.
Nous avions quelques règles strictes,
mais qu'on suit parce qu'on aime les gens,
qu'on aime la religion et qu'on est croyant.
Le mormonisme déterminait ce que vous portiez,
avec qui vous sortiez, qui vous épousiez.
Ça déterminait nos sous-vêtements.
Du fait de la religion, tous ceux que je connaissais
donnaient 10% de leurs revenus à l'église,
moi y compris.
Dès la distribution de journaux et le babysitting, je donnais 10%.
Du fait de la religion, j'entendais des parents dire à leurs enfants
qui partaient pour une mission prosélytique de deux ans
qu'ils préfèreraient les savoir morts
plutôt que de les voir rentrer sans honneur, en ayant pêché.
Du fait de la religion,
des enfants se suicidaient chaque année
car l'idée d'annoncer leur homosexualité à la communauté les terrifiait.
Mais également du fait de la religion,
peu importait où je vivais dans le monde,
j'avais des amis, une aide mutuelle instantanée.
Je m'y sentais en sécurité. C'était la sûreté et la clarté de ma vie.
On m'a aidée à élever ma petite fille.
C'est pour ça que je ne questionnais pas que seuls les hommes puissent diriger
et que j'acceptais
que les femmes ne puissent avoir l'autorité spirituelle de Dieu sur Terre :
la prêtrise.
J'autorisais des différences entre les hommes et les femmes
en termes de budget,
de conseils disciplinaires, de capacités à prendre des décisions.
J'offrais un laisser-passer à ma religion
parce que je l'adorais.
Jusqu'à ce que j'arrête
et que je me rende compte que je m'étais autorisée à être traitée
comme étant le personnel auxiliaire du vrai travail des hommes.
Je faisais face à cette contradiction qui était mienne
et j'ai rejoint d'autres activistes de ma communauté.
Nous avons travaillé très, très dur au cours des dix dernières années.
Nous avons commencé par la prise de conscience.
Vous ne pouvez pas changer ce que vous ne pouvez pas voir.
Nous avons commencé des podcasts, des blogs, des articles.
J'ai créé des listes sur les centaines de façons
dont les hommes et les femmes sont inégaux dans notre communauté.
Ensuite, nous avons mis en place des organismes de défense des droits.
Nous avons essayé des actions qu'on ne pouvait pas ignorer,
comme porter un pantalon à l'église et aller à des réunions d'hommes.
Cela semble être de petites choses,
mais à nous, les organisateurs, elles nous coûtaient énormément.
Nous avons perdu des relations, des emplois.
Nous avons reçu quotidiennement des mails de haine.
Nous étions attaqués dans les média sociaux et la presse.
Nous avons reçu des menaces de mort.
Nous avons perdu notre réputation dans notre communauté.
Certains ont été excommuniés.
La plupart d'entre nous sont passés en conseil de discipline
et ont été rejetés des communautés que nous aimions
car nous voulions les rendre meilleures, nous croyions qu'elles pouvaient l'être.
J'ai commencé à m'attendre à cette réaction de la part de mes proches.
Je sais ce que c'est d'avoir l'impression que quelqu'un essaye de vous changer
ou vous critiquer.
Mais ce qui m'a profondément choquée est que tout au long de ce travail,
j'ai reçu autant de vitriol de la gauche séculière
et avec autant de véhémence que la droite religieuse.
Mes amis séculiers n'ont pas réalisé que cette hostilité religieuse,
ces phrases : « Tous les religieux sont fous ou stupides »,
« Ne prête pas attention à la religion »,
« Ils sont homophobes et sexistes ».
Ce qu'ils ne comprenaient pas,
c'est que ce genre d'hostilité ne luttait pas contre l'extrémisme religieux
mais le nourrissait.
Ces débats ne fonctionnent pas, je le sais car je me souviens
de quelqu'un me disant que j'étais stupide d'être mormone.
Cela m'a poussée à nous défendre, moi et mes proches
et tout ce en quoi nous croyons, parce que nous ne sommes pas stupides.
La critique et l'hostilité ne fonctionnent pas et je ne les écoutais pas.
Quand j'entends ces arguments, cela me hérisse encore
parce que j'ai une famille et des amis.
Ce sont mes proches, et je suis la première à les défendre,
mais le problème est réel.
Comment respectons-nous les croyances religieuses de quelqu'un
quand nous les tenons encore responsables de la douleur ou les dégâts
que ces croyances ont pu causer à d'autres ?
C'est une question difficile. Je n'ai pas de réponse parfaite.
Mes parents et moi marchons depuis dix ans sur cette corde raide.
Ce sont des gens intelligents et charmants.
Laissez-moi essayer de vous aider à comprendre leur point de vue.
Dans le mormonisme, nous croyons qu'après la mort,
si vous respectez toutes les règles et suivez tous les rituels,
vous serez réunis de nouveau en tant que famille.
Et pour mes parents, que je fasse une chose aussi simple
que de ne pas avoir de manches, de montrer mes épaules,
me rend indigne.
Je ne serai pas avec la famille dans l'éternité.
Mais plus encore, mon frère est mort à 15 ans dans un tragique accident
et une petite chose comme celle-ci signifie que nous ne serons plus ensemble.
Et mes parents ne comprennent pas
qu'une chose telle que la mode ou les droits des femmes
m'empêche de revoir mon frère.
C'est à cet état d'esprit que nous faisons face
et la critique n'y change rien.
Mes parents et moi marchons sur cette corde raide,
expliquant nos avis, nous respectant mutuellement,
mais invalidant les croyances les plus fondamentales de chacun
de par notre mode de vie et c'est difficile.
Nous avons réussi à y parvenir
en allant outre ces carapaces protectrices
et en voyant l'intérieur moelleux de l'incrédulité et de la croyance
et en essayant de nous respecter en maintenant clairement les frontières.
L'autre point est que la gauche séculière et les athéistes et les orthodoxes
et la droite religieuse, ce qu'ils ne comprennent pas,
c'est pourquoi s'occuper d'activisme religieux.
Des centaines de personnes m'ont dit :
« Si vous n'aimez pas la religion, contentez-vous de partir. »
Pourquoi essayer de la changer ?
Parce que ce qu'on enseigne pendant le Sabbat
influence notre politique, notre politique de santé,
la violence dans le monde.
Ça influence l'éducation, l'armée, les décisions fiscales.
Ces lois sont légalement et culturellement codifiées.
En fait, ma propre religion a eu un effet énorme sur cette nation.
Durant la Proposition 8, mon église a collecté 22 millions de dollars
pour lutter contre le mariage homosexuel en Californie.
D'après les historiens politiques, il y a 40 ans,
sans l'opposition mormone à l'Equal Rights Amendment,
un Equal Rights Amendment serait aujourd'hui entré dans notre Constitution.
Combien de vies cela a-t-il impacté ?
Nous pouvons passer du temps à nous battre contre chacune
de ces petites lois et règles,
ou nous pouvons nous demander :
pourquoi est-ce que l'inégalité des sexes est un standard dans le monde entier ?
Pourquoi est-ce le postulat ?
Parce que la religion n'est pas seulement à la racine de la moralité
mais aussi à la racine de la normalité.
Les religions peuvent libérer ou subjuguer,
donner du pouvoir ou exploiter, conforter ou détruire.
Et les personnes qui font changer les tendances de l'éthique et de la morale
ne sont pas souvent celles qui dirigent.
Les religions ne peuvent être rejetées ou ignorées.
Nous devons les prendre au sérieux.
Mais il n'est pas simple d'influencer une religion, nous venons d'en parler.
Je vais vous dire ce que mes proches ont fait.
Mes groupes sont petits, on nous compte en centaines,
mais nous avons un impact énorme.
Pour la première fois, des images de femmes sont accrochées au mur
avec celles d'hommes.
Les femmes sont autorisées à prier dans nos réunions ecclésiales,
elles n'avaient jamais été à des conférences générales.
Et la semaine dernière, dans un mouvement historique,
trois femmes ont été invitées à trois conseils d'administration
qui supervisent toute l’Église.
Il y a eu dans la communauté mormone des évolutions visibles
qui ouvrent la discussion sur l'inégalité des sexes.
Nous avons créé un espace, quitte à être méprisés,
pour que des femmes plus conservatives puissent intervenir et changer les choses,
pour que les mots « femmes » et « prêtrise » puissent être accolés.
Je n'avais jamais vu cela.
Ma fille et mes nièces héritent d'une religion que je n'ai jamais eue,
qui est plus égalitaire -- nous avons eu un impact.
Ce n'était pas simple de faire la queue
pour essayer d'entrer dans ces réunions pour hommes.
Nous étions des centaines
et, en arrivant à la porte, une par une,
on nous disait : « Désolé, cette réunion est uniquement pour les hommes. »
et nous devions partir et regarder les hommes aller en réunion.
Certains avaient 12 ans,
ils étaient escortés et passaient devant nous alors que nous attendions.
Mais aucune femme dans cette file d'attente n'oubliera ce jour,
et aucun petit garçon passé devant nous n'oubliera ce jour.
Si nous étions une entreprise internationale ou un gouvernement,
et que cela s'était produit,
ça aurait été un scandale.
Mais nous ne sommes qu'une religion.
Nous faisons tous partie des religions.
Nous ne pouvons pas continuer à voir ainsi la religion
parce que cela n'affecte pas que moi, cela affecte ma fille
et chacune de vos filles et les opportunités qu'elles ont,
ce qu'elles peuvent porter, qui elles peuvent aimer et épouser,
si elles ont accès à la santé génésique.
Nous devons réclamer la moralité dans un contexte séculier
qui crée la vigilance et la responsabilité
pour les religions à travers le monde.
Mais nous devons le faire respectueusement,
que cela nourrisse la coopération et non pas l'extrémisme.
Nous pouvons y parvenir par le biais d'actes de bravoure qu'on ne peut ignorer,
en nous battant pour l'égalité des sexes.
Il est temps que la moitié de la population mondiale
ait une voix et l'égalité au sein des religions du monde,
des églises, synagogues, mosquées et sanctuaires dans le monde.
Je travaille pour mes proches. Que faites-vous pour les vôtres ?
(Applaudissements)